inédit qui me vient comme ça et c'est
une petite battle de rire de blague
le principe et sa maman deux équipes une
âme à droite et une à gauche et il va
falloir s'affronter dans des battles de
blagues d'accord le premier qui rira le
travail vermeil sabah le premier série
perd une [ __ ] a perdu d'accord
inquiète le renard faut bien sauver
l'équipe qui marquera le plus de points
qui remporte évidemment le match mais
surtout l'équipe adverse
or un gage à est le gage n'est pas sympa
oh là non il est horrible
maxime bonjour le gaz est épouvantable
s'est même cyril qu'il a acquis vous
dire que lui rigole pas tous les gages
on ne triche pas premier duo déjà on
rien c'est daniel moreau montant du
dividende est horrible si ça marche
prenez vos blagues alors il en faut
plusieurs hockey a coûté tant que
j'aimerais pas je laisse daniel démarré
au neuro jeunes avaient juste voilà
qu'est ce qu'un chinois avec des
écouteurs chine avec des écouteurs un
mp3 vim
c'est pas mal ma daniel mais je pense
que tu vas préféré ça c'est l'histoire
d'un poil mais c'est pas toi isa avant
il était bien émana du bien commun pas
mal non
la confiance vient d' animal est sourd
hormis jean michel maire le cra par
boukari fait quoi c'est pas drôle daniel
s'est passé
ces zones est bien parti est-ce que tu
savais que la lampe elle torche et le pq
aussi cédé en plus sinon je fais mes
matches nuls en battant les indiens
matis leur argent en bourse
je sais pas qu'est ce que ça rapporte
beaucoup de sioux merci beaucoup
[Rires]
si le deuxième oui c'était vraiment le
théâtre et la télévision sur la mesure
concrète comment ce qu'on a créé un peu
le décret mêmes jeux l'annoncent l'adulé
[Applaudissements]
se joue beaucoup sur internet qui fait
le buzz
oui oui mais je n'ai pas cité les noms
j'ai un jour c'est voulait d'abord
annoncée de faire une blague
on m'a mise mais qui me fait rire vous
amuse c'est de croire qu'il discutait
hier un colis et loti lisbonne vient
alors c'est ce que voulait dire
la séquence est donc énormément rire
attention monsieur on peut mourir de
rire
il avait mal à l'épaule à la voile a
placé